so with that I want to end this a little
bit early and bring on my brand-new
cultural correspondent we've been
looking around since I started this show
it's very important to me that we give
the next generation a chance to come up
and teach old fogies like me something
that you know maybe I don't know about
the culture so let's bring them on we
have our new Michael Nolt show cultural
correspondent Andy Andy millennial
thanks for coming on yo Andy as a
millennial what is your take on our
culture broadly right now well speaking
is a millennial and I have to speak as a
little millennial because I've never
read a book and I haven't seen a movie
that was made before 2007 so when I say
speaking as a millennial that's actually
the only thing I can bring to this
conversation of my millennial miss you
know my Mallette my essential millennial
miss my millennialism you might say and
and as a millennial I think I can speak
for all Millennials and can tell you the
kind of world in which we Millennials
live and so that's why I reference that
whenever I say anything whatsoever
and you know I think as a millennial I
feel that the culture is in serious
trouble you know we have these new
things that were you know rock and roll
music I think is making people you know
immoral we have our new cult rockers
bunny
Andrew Clavin famed novelist and dealer
wire show host I I did almost break on
the I am a millennial and so because I
haven't read a book you know remember on
election night you played poker with a
perfectly straight face asks me senator
Warren do you when you look at mr. Trump
do you ever feel your fingers itch in
for the tomahawk the pinnacle of my
deadpan you know that big blonde wig and
Milenio thank you for coming on a
pleasure we have to sorry what you were
doing in here my god these young locks
himself in a room thank you sir
so we have to talk about one of our
favorite subjects yes feminism that we
have you talk about this wonderfully
feminist response to Milania yeah and
you know one of our favorite websites
and I will take credit for you for
introducing this is everyday feminism
calm yeah a true work of art I'm not
convinced it's not satire what why has
feminism become such a force well I
think just about everything I mean first
of all this thing with eat with stiletto
heels was unbelievable there's Trump
hatred you know it's wonderful is all
these people in Texas are obviously
rising to this level of nobility and
grandeur and heroism and they're all the
people that the media hates making
themselves look so bad you know I think
the left is the same thing over and over
again they decide that there's an
injustice and then they adopt the values
of the oppressor or the person they
think of is the oppressor so they think
that men have oppressed women which by
the way in the West completely untrue
right I mean that's the first thing I
mean the thing is in a society that's
just starting out and this week women
have a very special role to play which
is the role of burying children and you
have to protect them and you have to
keep them out away from the wars and
things like that
we're so safe now that a lot of that
stuff is gone by the boards but that's
only because in the modern world we're
so safe so they decide there's this
injustice and then they say well we want
to be you what the oppressor is so if
men are making money why can't women
make money if men work why shouldn't
women work if if men are strong why
shouldn't women you know it's men are
dying younger why shouldn't women die
who and which now they do there and it's
so dumb because essentially men and
women are the only kinds of people who
are different you don't really believe
that black people and white people are
different per se you know I'm its
culture and there's a lot of effects but
you know but men and women are actually
different they actually have different
strengths different qualities different
things that make the men that
than women and sure there's always a
bell curve you know there's always
different people have fallen right not
not all manner as macho as you and I are
more a fan of course you know I'd say
you can't expect that kind of level very
top of the mantra though but but you
know I think this whole idea that we
should value women and conservatives
fall for - they'll say you know you want
to see feminism how about a woman with a
gun and I think you want to see feminism
how about woman with a baby it's
probably scarier - probably more
intimidating exactly you know how about
a woman who's nurturing how about a
woman who's tender how about a woman who
doesn't care as much about money because
she's doing something more important you
know they even have these things where
they'll say if you paid a housewife for
everything she did it would cost
millions actually if you paid a
housewife for the actual physical labor
she did wouldn't cost very much at all
what she's devoting to it creating a
home and creating a moral universe and
creating a family that's invaluable you
can making the man's sane and you know I
think in a man of man you know yeah
that's right you know sweet little lease
has been gone now for a couple weeks
visiting your family I know my life is
in shambles my apartment is just not
sure Michael we had a great time
shooting that's all I do is I go
shooting and drinking that's pretty much
all I've been up to my wife leaves town
about two days later I'm out in the
woods I'm in deer it's my teeth no I'm
just running down dear yeah no I mean I
think that is and they say well why
should why should a woman only have
value in what she does for a man
anything well we all have value and what
we do for one another as writers you
know so it's just it's just a an
absolutely materialist greedy that has
adopted the values of the people the
supposed values of the people they hate
you know you see it with like an Tifa
right and Tifa they say that the
fascists for the oppressors and so they
become fascist yeah that's right they
literally wear black shirts you know
yeah do you think this has always been
inherent in feminism it with you know
this indiscernible 'ti of the sexes the
sexes women should just be men the sexes
should be the same they can't complement
one another has that always been in
first way of second wave feminism or is
it is it blossoming now as its
new I think it's a question of
revolution eating its own children I
have a theory that a lot of these
changes come at the time that they're
supposed to come you know that that when
women when this the civilization gets
established women start asking for more
rights because they're let there in a
way they're less valuable as women
children become less valuable
so women become less valuable as the
bearers of children and so they want
more things to do to give them value I
think that feminists attach themselves
to those changes I was there you know as
a millennial I was there when some of
this stuff was getting started and it
was pretty easy you know women said we
want to get in we want to work we want
to do these things neighbors thought
that's fair that's that's pretty fair
but the feminists the radical feminists
attached themselves to that right and
then essentially accuse you if you
oppose feminism and I am an
anti-feminist I'm I'm not like a you
know sort of pro feminist I'm an
anti-feminist but they accused you
thinking that women shouldn't have
choices and rights I believe a woman
should choose whatever she wants to do
each one is an individual I believe in
it I'm an individualist whenever the
circle of feminism and the circle of
individualism intersect I'm a FEMINIST
aniseh poll the nurse lucky you're gonna
find that but as we see with Melania
Trump they're not really offering
freedom what they're really offering is
another way of a prep you wanna do is
turn the oppression on us they want to
say well women were oppressed now men
will be oppressed you know that's not
that's no way to build a society I think
the changes that came for women the
giving them more you know choices and
things like that are great but I really
think this wave of feminism has
accomplished nothing but bad and has
attached itself to those good changes
and sort of said we did that when they
just didn't yeah it seems this third
wave seems destructive in a in both a
practical sense but also in a
theoretical sense that seems as
post-structuralist it a lot of these
theorists they use lowercase letters to
to write their name so it is it's
attached to an intellectual movement
that deconstructs culture and you know I
think it was Chesterton wrote that
feminists posit something to the effect
of feminists posit that when a woman
serves her boss that's freedom and
woman helps her husband to that slave I
always say that I didn't know chasers
and said they basically say to you don't
serve a man who loves you and will
dedicate his life to you and will help
you raise your children I'll help you
support dedicated to a guy who would
back over you and not even notice you
were dead you know I mean that's it
makes absolutely no sense and it really
you know it's it's something very
important because the entire human
perception of the world is divided into
yin and yang but the simple reason that
there are men and women you know I mean
they always want to say well men and
women are exactly the same but a
transgender guy is a man with a woman
inside you say well wait how does he
know the same how does you know he's a
man with a woman he's just a dolt is a
double man what's the diff you know so
they're they're really taking something
very essential to the human perception
of the world and damaging it making
people afraid to acknowledge it and
trying to bully people out of
acknowledging it I think it has made
speaking as a millennial I think it has
made millennial dating a nightmare I
think it's made millennial marriage a
nightmare I think people don't know it
oh and you know what else it's done it's
ruined two movies like you can't go to a
movie and see the girl get rescued
anymore because she's supposed to be so
strong and it's boring not to see the
girl get rescued most women have that
fantasy approach and every man wants to
rescue a woman that's all we want to do
that's all we do that is all that is
true I speaking as a millennial as well
I I you have noticed that that you know
I mean I haven't dated in about a
hundred thousand years at this point but
you don't you don't ask women on dates
it's all this kind of hanging out it's
the way that you would talk to a buddy
sex is easier which is cool I mean
that's great guys yeah absolutely but it
is destructive and you know your novels
yeah don't present a feminist vision of
the world because I don't believe it's
true I mean I you know I will present
women who are tough for manly or
masculine or stuff like that but I will
not write women the way feminists write
women because I've never met a woman who
resembled anything like those women I
mean you know I've met women who were
very tough I've met women who are very
manly you know masculine
but there's still not there's still
women at some level and I just really
don't write feminism because it doesn't
exist it doesn't exist as an actual real
thing it just doesn't ring true it
represents a vision of the world that
none of us in our experience yeah
believes to be true even the people who
are propagating it probably that's right
well of course that's why they you know
that's why you get these things where
they say like I was so upset that he
said you know women aren't the same as
men that I I almost fainted you know
what you know when he called me
emotional I almost burst into tears
it's just it doesn't make any sense in
it and you know college professors can
afford to lie but novelists already
fiction they have to tell that's right
yeah speaking of your stories that don't
present a feminist view of the world
I'll say we've got one that we're
working on around the clock in this
broom closet of a studio in this very
room we are creating the cure for the
Clavin this weekend another kingdom you
were on which by the way and this is the
only nice thing I will ever say to you
ever you were doing an excellent job
you are the performer of this story that
I wrote and you I'm watching you act it
out and do the voices and all this stuff
and it's really actually you almost have
some talent did we get that on tape
put that on my IMDB or something first
thank you very much I mean even I'm
listening to it going hey this is pretty
under day it is it is a great story it's
all really great it does ring a little
true to me because it's a bad this
failed Hollywood guy he wanders into a
kingdom that is probably less surreal
than Sepulveda Boulevard that walked off
of the studios but it's gonna be rough
and we're releasing it actually don't
know exactly when we're releasing its
it's gonna be shortly after Labor Day
and we're gonna bring it out on Fridays
to make up for the you because you don't
have a show on Friday I don't have a
show Friday either our desperate fans
will and hopefully they'll stave off
some of these disasters yeah
the world the world needs something to
fill that yeah that's right absolutely
so we'll try we'll release it hopefully
a little after Labor Day it'll be a
weekend release we'll do like one
Episode a week and people can write in
and send all their angry comments
excellent well Andy Andy millennial
thank you for being here it's a pleasure
to have this great new cultural
correspondent Andy millennial everybody
thank you very much